my interest started from seeing the
physics books in the school library and
reading bits of them and thinking whoa
this stuff is real I thought how could
you not study astronomy you can begin to
understand the universe but I know it's
not everyone I like John Green's quote
about how certain books are read by
everyone could fix the world because I
feel that if everyone stood back and
looked at Earth's place in the universe
people may change how they behave it's
strange that not everyone will know or
even try to find out about the mysteries
around them and that would be a cool
thing to change other Sciences are
important but physics is different in
the way that it not only allows us to
better understand ourselves but offers a
glance into how we got here it is a form
of religion for me it allows us to begin
to understand how everything is the way
it is and even though we will never know
everything it is still comforting while
considering future options I have never
been able to discard studying physics
than astronomy
I don't think I could leave it behind
knowing that there is so much out there
waiting to be discovered
that I don't even understand I don't
know if I will ever discover something
entirely new but at least I'll feel
great knowing that I can be a part in
some way of the extraordinary research
that is exploring our neighborhood